parce que c'est un coyote ou un loup
c'est difficile à dire entre que je vous
dis que c'est à montréal c'est une vidéo
qui a été tournée par un automobiliste
dans le quartier saint michel et la
vidéo circule depuis hier au l'animal a
été aperçu quand même assez gros seins a
été aperçu au coin du boulevard saint
michel et de la rue champdoré et selon
la ville de montréal le coyote est de
plus en plus présents en ville ça
pourrait très bien en être il aurait élu
domicile aux alentours de l'ancienne
carrière miron
la ville dit que le coyote s'est adapté
à son milieu de vie urbain en vivant
surtout la nuit
il se déplace aux abords des autoroutes
et des lignes de transport d'électricité
si montréal ont été attaqués par un
coyote l'été dernier mais la ville
affirme qu'il ne faut pas s'en inquiéter
un trappeur capture les animaux
problématiques